There's the,
the chemical makeup of
the classic psychedelics.
You see,
they all have the same
fundamental structure.
This is serotonin.
That's the one of the major
brain neurotransmitters.
And so what happens with the
psychedelics is that they,
they altered the,
they alter the brain function by
altering the neurochemical utilization of
serotonin.
They changed the manner in which
the serotonergic systems work.
And that is the serotonin system is very
basic system may cause when you're an
embryo and your brain is developing,
it's the serotonin projections that
basically orchestrate the development of
your brain.
So they're,
and they're very archaic circuits,
very,
very archaic circuits.
So,
and this is the paper,
I think I stole this from
a silicide Ben Griffiths,
who's been doing a lot of this research
siliciden can occasion mystical type
experiences having substantial and
sustained personal meaning and spiritual
significance.
So why,
that's a good question.
Right?
Like so,
so here's a question for you.
It is beyond dispute that human beings
are capable of religious experience.
Why?
Why is that?
Exactly?
And they're like,
you can associate with psychosis,
but that doesn't work is the
theory doesn't hold a theory,
doesn't hold water.
It's not the same thing.
So why is it there?
Exactly.
And it,
it's not an easy thing to figure out.
Like I've been trying to figure,
I'm always trying to figure out a
biological explanation for everything,
right?
Because if you want to find something to
stand on and you want to make sure that
it can resist the challenge.
And so if I can find an explanation
for something that's reductionistic and
materialistic and biological,
then I'm going for that.
But that's a tough one.
Consciousness is a tough one.
The,
the moral sense is a tough one.
They're not easy things to crack.
The Big Bang is a tough one.
So,
you know,
I mean,
a cynic might say that maybe.
Yeah.
Sometimes when people
are close to suicide,
they'll have a mystical experience,
you know,
and you maybe you say,
well,
it's a last ditch attempt of your brain
to delude you into thinking that your
life has some significance.
You know?
And that's a plausible theory,
but I don't think it accounts for
the generality of the phenomena,
so,
so I don't buy it.